she
all right uh so I
am officially opening the subcommittee
on House Bill 146 6 6
yes um after the hearing there were two
things that were clear we needed help
with the first was how fiscal works and
how do how would it work with it and I
asked representative Wier to give us
some information and I also spoke with
the Department of Safety to see why they
thought they needed full five full-time
employees for this sort of thing and
they said they would send somebody so
representative wer you were from the
Department of Safety y Rob the director
home
security excellent all right we're good
buddies so your choice what you want to
hear from first but I think we need the
information well let's if representative
wer wouldn't mind um oh I will well all
right representative wer um is going to
talk about the I guess the fiscal
committee ask
ECT so the purpose of the fiscal
committee is the
Constitution excuse me requires that the
the legislature appropriates money
otherwise you can't spend it so we
serve as a as a part of that process by
having five members of the house finance
committee five members of the sometimes
it's the Senate finance committee
usually the president of Senate wants to
get in there whether he's on that
committee or not but anyway um so we
serve that purpose we meet months or
month the majority of what we deal with
we have 20 or 30 requests typically each
month plus we look at some audits
because the fiscal committee by law
appoints the legislative budget
assistant the legislative budget
assistant has staffs has about eight
that work in the budget Division and
about 30 that work in the audit division
and they do performance audits as well
as as is finance audits so we usually
have some audit reports at the end of
the thing but the basic most of our
requests come from Grants that have come
through the federal government to
various agencies well the various
agencies can't spend that Grant until it
is appropriated so we serve that purpose
by looking at those grants and then
quite often they don't use it up in the
time they they've alloted so we have a
lot to extend the grant deadline and we
have them according to how much money
there was and what how it was
established we split the thing up into
several categories according to what the
law is and whether it's from
non-government sources or whether it's
from federal sources and so on and we go
through all those requests and and look
them over and see you know what what the
uh request is at one point I uh found
the ey of the governor and and big
Pharma by saying I don't think we should
accept this $22 million to hire 15 more
people and give them Vans and send them
out going door too to insist you take
the covid shot when I was hearing all
these adverse reactions I think we would
be liable for damages if we were forcing
it on people and then they were anyway
that's that's an aside but that was one
thing I turned down and and made quite a
tussle but um so when representative a
um Aaron and I spoke about this money I
said let them come to fiscal but it has
to be a request through one of the
agencies to come to to come to fiscal
saying you know we'd like to accept this
Grant and dispense dispense it here
we've also had U rearrangements
somebody's got more money in one part of
their budget than than they needed than
they needed in that budget but they
needed in another part so again they
have to come to us because we have set
that in a law of how that appropriation
should be spent so if you had more money
for equipment than you needed but you
didn't have enough for con
subcontractors so you wanted to change
money from here to here then you have to
come to us again for permission so those
are just kind of procedures that ensure
that the appropriating process was F
that in fact the
legislature and the guys of the fiscal
committee has approved this so that's
that's quite a bit of things that come
to us every month and U go ahead um so
are you aware that there is uh as
representative eron has talked about a
like an emergency or disaster fund that
fiscal can yes access all right and do
you think that the law can be changed so
that the
requesting entity could be from a
town yes it would seem that that would
be the first place you you'd see it and
as you know we've had several things
that came down from FEMA usually two
years later and you try to make up for
all the money initially you you
exhausted all the resources of the of
the local government trying to to stop
the flood or fix the road or whatever
and then it takes a while to get through
his agency and then they re they report
to the feds and then the FEMA money
comes but we're forever seeing things
two years later that that we finally
giving millions of dollars to some to
fix things a lot of it's going to our
own do and much of it's going to the
town
do okay so if if I understand you
correctly a town could ask fiscal
directly to allocate money from the the
state Emergency Management fund not
federal state we don't have that
Authority yet it has it we okay if we
were to put to say that the town ask
fiscal for the money you would be able
to say yes we can allocate money from if
the law chated fund if the Law changes
right now all right so we don't need to
involve of any agency we just say the
town um aworth is an example says we
need $100,000 right now to fix this one
road that got flooded out again and put
it on the agenda and fiscal would say
yes there's 100,000 in our state
Emergency Management fund here's your
Grant so that that could could could do
it I think the state emergency fund is
is less than a million dollar this it
might not be enough to fix some of the
problems that come but the larger things
would would take federal grants because
as representative Aaron and I have
discussed this town is too small they
have much of a budget to be fixing mil
monthly million dollar damages so those
would take longer but the way I read
that Emergency Management fund you would
think that that would enable them to
come directly to the fiscal but it has
not happened in my 12 years there on
that committee well what what we were
hearing from uh representative Aaron is
that uh they were looking for immediate
help to for example get the main road
coming into town uh operable so that
probably wouldn't take I hope a million
dollars but the way it's been done in
the past you you go borrow the money
especially if the local bank is
concerned because they want the the
people coming into town you could go to
the local Bank you could make a loan you
could get the money to hire the
contractors and so on to fix it then
you're going to put in a report you you
keep track of every penny that you spent
to do this and you have all these good
records that you can say yes so many man
hours so many contractors and so on and
then you would go to that emergency fund
this this is a the reason this bill is
is to say we don't want to follow the
normal procedure we want to get some
cash out immediately so that or within a
month at at the regular fiscal meeting
so that the town can fix their main road
or whatever as a grant from the state
Emergency Management fund and not
involve the feds at
all right so is that right that's that
the intent of what you're looking for
yes and and the the problem with the
loan process be they get a loan from the
state or a loan from masoma Bank think
is that when you have when a town goes
out to get a loan they first have to
have a special town meeting to get
approval from from the voters and a
special town meeting process could take
up to three months because you have to
hire a bond attorney you have to notice
the meeting you have to get it approved
by Dr uh there's a whole process for
putting setting up a special town
meeting that's the problem with the loan
process and that's why are seeking to
have grant money
accessible within a week a month as soon
as possible for the town to use so that
they have funds to um address immediate
concerns all these things are slowed up
by the assessment how much do you need
and when is it going to be
spent okay that that can take excessive
right but
um what I want to know is the I
understand the emergency State emergency
fund has something like $45,000 in it
would a a check within a month for
$40,000 get atworth able to get going on
their requests for more detailed
assessments and all that would be
helpful um you know certainly they would
have they would have to exhaust their
present resources and keep very careful
track of what they spent and I can
assume the town can keep track of their
expenditures but I mean that that's the
sort of thing that I got the impression
was really needed you don't want to have
the the state come in with a $10 million
Grant to fix your road because that's
going to take as long as FEMA right
exactly what you want is a is a little
bit upfront so you can hire people to do
the assessments put up a temporary
Bridge or reroute some road right yeah
yeah and I mean you know you know and
and the thing is that you don't want to
have this fund fund a million dollars
worth of work or $2 million worth of
work because whatever work a grant would
fund from the state would then be
ineligible for any kind of reimbursement
from FEMA coming back yeah would so
that's what I'm saying should we redo
this so that the maximum amount is
50,000
say and but it comes out quickly yeah I
mean would that help
because I I gathered the impression that
the process of really figuring out
lengthy yeah um I I Even Say closer to a
100,000 rather than
50,000 we could 50,000 doesn't go far
these days doesn't go very far when when
you're doing you know trying to um do
EXT fix extensive damage or at least
well no I I think it's more a matter
matter of you know fix fix your ma Main
Road temporarily and then start dealing
with the application process and the
loan process and the grant process all
the other
funding um because that that that's what
I'm leaning towards saying we should do
is just say ask for a modest amount of
money get it relatively quickly and then
proceed with the normal uh process is is
there currently a procceed
for I don't know I would guess fiscal to
um mandate putting perhaps a million
dollars into that
fund that that could be a request again
from Emergency Management if they come
in and he says you know the amounts of
are so minor that you can barely fix one
little pothole well and I'm thinking
because uh obviously sometimes when
these natural disasters happen it can
involve two or three small towns and so
that's what I'm thinking if you've got
three towns saying we need 40,000 boom
you're over the 45 quickly oh yeah so
all right well we'd have to allocate
yeah yeah we we've done a bit of
backfilling where people said here's how
much we had to spend at dot we spent all
this extra money um we've overspent this
part of our budget uh over this
unfortunate problem now we need to have
more money put into our budget from
somewhere else that would be the kind of
thing we'd get from like the do so if if
they can get involved especially if it's
a state
road um then you know it's they have an
easier process because they have more
depth of funds to draw
on okay so I think that all yeah yeah I
I think the important things is that
fiscal can move money from anywhere to
anywhere else pretty much and that the
town assuming we added it into statute
the town could could request it directly
from fiscal without requiring yeah
anybody else if you put that in statute
then but I mean obviously with do and
Emergency Management coming in and
support if because they they have a
little more dep of funds they can draw
on whereas this you know if it's 50,000
and it hardly starts to help with the
with the
problem well I'm not sure we want to
displace FEMA exactly but I don't think
aworth can properly deal with FEMA
without some cash up front right and so
that's what I my my my thinking which
may or may not be with representative sh
is thinking is that we help aworth apply
for FEMA using State funds to you know
patch patch one road maybe because f is
likely to come by will cover
75% and 12 a half% from the town 12 a
half% from the state typical and some of
the grants so it it's not automatic that
they're going to cover everything and
you're still going to be perhaps in debt
in the town for a while because of what
happened um sometimes towns have
insurance that they can try and collect
from and sometimes that takes years well
I personally wouldn't ensure aworth are
for
floods but you know these are all things
that can be looked at but you know I
thought there was a way for Judy to get
it quickly through Emergency Management
and um we found out that that we're
going to talk to them next yeah yeah but
clearly if emergeny management is there
saying yes we there's there's been a
disaster and an emergency in aworth and
we support helping them get through it
yeah and and the process is is far long
than it took to destroy the
road uh would the would the form of this
coming from through fiscal from this
emergency fund just be termed a grant is
would that be the proper yes it would
fund
okay thank you um I think we'll hear
Management I have to say his folks have
been great they've been really wonderful
to work with
and I appreciate that sorry this speaker
is like right like I'm like which side
of
the so Rob buckton director of Homeland
Security emergency management the
question that was posed was regarding to
the phisical note that was attached to
the bill and uh does HSM need additional
staff to facilitate a $5 million state
run grant program okay
um all of our employees in hscm are
covered by some form of management cost
that's actually received from FEMA and
other locations so whether it's C Brook
station for a portion of the agency or
from the federal government um under the
rules of the
disaster relief program from FEMA I
can't utilize those management costs to
manage your fund so that's we were like
okay what is the what is the bandwidth
that they're looking to
create what is the funding mechanism
that we're looking at and we look at
right now we're managing 11 open
disasters unfortunately the disaster the
storm rate is increasing not decreasing
unfortunately we had a event in December
of this year that we're working through
right
now
um the the process for FEMA is lengthy
as both representative Aaron and
representative wheeler know like this is
a long process um and it's a
reimbursement reimbursement program so
we we have to find the middle of the
road as to what the scope of you're
looking to develop and say okay is this
going to be a continuous funded program
is this a onetime fund what what are you
looking to create so when they said hey
here's a new program coming
on it looks at $5 million this time
what's the growth potential going to
look like hey we need to stand this up
with some additional staff that's funded
directly from there uh so that that's at
the end of the day that's just kind of
there's if I may yes the there's you
know two different approaches to it one
is to say that we would provide
substitute funding for instead of going
through the FEMA process because it will
be quicker and easier for everybody and
less paperwork but that
requires your operation to
manage the other thing is to
say a small town can't properly deal
with an emergency dealing with FEMA and
the assessments and all the all getting
a calling a town meeting for a loan in
any reasonable length of time and we
want to give them a grant so that they
can get the process started which is not
exactly what representative Aaron was
thinking about but from the testimony I
think that may be useful makes sense
yeah and so that you could say you know
give them 50 or
$100,000 and include it in the costs
that you're applying to FEMA because it
you know when you wake up in the in the
morning and your main roads are
gone you know it's going to be a lot but
you don't know how much right right
absolutely I I mean I understand so if
that were to be the case and you'd have
a
fund I I was thinking that say aworth
could go to fiscal and say I
want 50 or $100,000 from the emergency
fund we'll keep track of how we spend
it and your department would say it
appears there was a disaster that
affected a aworth and when we do the
process we'll be we'll be supporting it
and so you won't necessarily be
administering the fund so much as
saying this is available for the towns
and they can use it
for their share of of the U or even the
State share you don't care who gets
counted for it we don't have to wait a a
month for a fiscal meeting we've called
them within a couple of days there was
something urgent right well if you know
like say six small towns in in in um san
county had a flood they would all come
and say Hey give us a give us a hand to
get going because meanwhile do is
invading the place and looking looking
for what happened and they'll be the
town is saying oh my God we're going to
have to borrow a fortune again but it'll
take a while to have the town
meeting and it's even going to take a
while to get an analysis from an
engineer based upon past here's the
pictures here's what's here's what's
happened how much washed out I think
interestingly enough one of the things
and and I know we're talking about
aworth is remember the dot is going to
come in and take care of State Road and
they certainly will uh give a hand
within a certain distance of State Road
um you had a lot of damage that was
outside of state road yeah and that that
was really one of the challenges with
that particular
community and you know some of them were
um pretty major cross sections to be
able to get around town
so between some of the programming that
we've established for uh Public Works
Mutual Aid where other communities can
come in and working with local vendors
like there's been some movement in
regards to how do we leverage and expand
resources to get them more support so
some of the problems though with mutual
Aid yeah is that if you have several
communities in the same area they don't
have corre correct
AB because they're using absolutely um
so what we had we had in the July 2021
flood um what we we weren't able to get
um um um anything from Mutual Aid we
were able to get things like um barriers
and signs and sandbags and that kind of
thing from the do the the regional do
stations yeah um and and David rodrig
was wonderful in helping us do that but
um that also took a lot of time to
coordinate and and put that together um
the other
the other issues that um you know we ran
into was just
uh the the the time aspect you know we
we had do crews around um mostly in
getting contractors you know people were
out working on whatever other issues and
it was it was difficult to even get the
people to do the work we ended up having
to set up a program within our town
where Town's people could register as
volunteers to the town and bring their
back hose or their construction material
whatever to help fix things so we had
volunteers coming in from our town to
pitching in to to opening these roads
and
um you if we didn't have the people
helping us out I don't know where we be
oh that's what what towns do I mean we
had the Mother's Day fled in six a
couple of people brought their back hose
around to uh contain the evulsion yeah
and then you know on top of that all you
can't do any work without getting Dees
permits and that whole permitting
process too can be timec
consuming so um that that's a whole
other issue
yeah one last question sir um you've
been listening to this this whole idea
of changing the the process you don't
see any part of that as disrupting what
you excuse me what you need to do in
order to help towns is that no this is
another tool in the full box
potentially just wanted to be sure
covered all the bases okay thank you I
did want can I ask director a question
yeah so with regard to a town obtaining
some grant money and being able to do
some work to open up
roads right
away how does that play
into later reimbursement through F
because that's the biggest argument I
found against doing something like this
is that if a town gets money from the
state or anywhere else and does some
work to open up a road temporarily that
that may
jeopardize the town from or make them
ineligible to get funds for FEMA to fix
that road permanently yeah and that
certainly is uh a change that FEMA is
looking at right now a lot of states
have looked at their disaster relief
programs because storms are coming more
frequently right um and how do they put
funds aside that are going to be spent
locally and then have them be
recoverable right and and that is I
don't have a FEMA policy that can hand
hand you and say it's going to be
recoverable yet but that is a
conversation that's being had because we
recognize that that you
know we all you know every emergency
starts locally until it isn't anymore
right and it gets big enough that we
need to give State support and then
Federal support you know and and the
federal uh disaster relief program has
been challenged because of the increase
in number of Storms and the length of
time it takes and what they we've
expressed as emergency management staff
is you need to also provide opportunity
that when a state does put a foot
forward to put some money aside it has
to be part of the recoverable value that
you're going to reimburse to the to the
state or to the community so we're we're
work we're trying to work that out as
you know this is a fluid today and that
doesn't need State legislation it needs
Federal yeah and and that's more that's
more policy not even legislation it's
not a a change to the staff act that
would be a policy that they would put
internally so we have a situation now
where we still have cranebrook road
which is totally destroyed and out and
not even existing anymore where um we
have folks in town who are willing to do
the work temporarily to fill in places
to make the road passable and we've
asked FEMA can we do this temporary work
and not be penalized for it later on and
they said oh yeah sure it's fine but
then a month later they changed their
mind
so now we're still in the situation of
still waiting to hear whether we can do
this temporary work and make the road
passable or not and so here we are
sitting with a road that's
still not usable gone whatever Fe is
beyond our control yeah that's beyond
our control but I just wanted to give an
example of okay you know how even a town
can be so paralyzed based on what the
federal uh federal guidelines have been
because we're afraid to do certain work
because oh my God then we won't ever get
reimbursed when we come to do the
permanent
work it's a
problem anyway
75% correct it's a 7525 for the 2021
Chang
now
okay I think we've heard enough to start
looking at language and see what we need
to
change yeah yeah I think the um I had to
agree with you we've got a couple of of
ways we can move but I think we want to
thank you very much um question so this
is going be your subcommittee you're G
make a
recommendation yes yes we'll we'll work
out well if we can work out some
Language by the scheduled exact we will
have it if we can't we might decide
um simplifying something like this I'm
thinking also though if if we endorse
the policy uh and send it on to finance
because they're the ones that have to
work out that mechanis that's why it's
early bill is going to
fin yeah because yeah like represent Aon
I represent was devastated and I think
there a few other communities that were
not as bad but we our towns in solivan
County really need help so what do and
and we seem to be having fiveyear floods
now instead of 100e FL unfortunately the
weather patterns and it's affecting our
infastructure
okay but but I think
re revisioning it from disaster relief
to a helping hand to deal with disaster
relief would make the the whole process
a lot simpler right because I think the
federal is fine but takes a while just
the town's got to deal with
whether it's
a you know a grant to get through the
so those that's s
separate this is this is after a
disaster so they're two two different
commit a
lot app that we'll see you soon see you
soon okay do you know and otherwise I
were theth this thing that screwed up
the
pharmacy punishment if somebody did
something wrong in Pharmacy and he said
author it's probably
hp2